The hype for Avengers Infinity War is reaching
boiling point and Kevin Feige has now confirmed
there are going to be real character deaths
in the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan and in
this video, I'm going to explain why I think
one specific character that hasn't typically
appeared on everyone's death-lists will be
killed by Thanos in the film.
I'm also starting a new Marvel giveaway – to
enter, make sure you're a subscriber and tell
me in the comments who you think won't make
it out of Infinity War alive.
And I'll announce the winner of my last giveaway
later in this video.
Obviously, speculation and potential spoilers
ahead for Infinity War.
It's generally thought that Marvel are going
to hit fans big in Avengers Infinity War and
kill off someone like Cap or Iron Man.
After all, Tony did have that vision in Age
of Ultron of his fellow heroes strewn lifeless
on a rock in outer space.
But a recent EW interview with Josh Brolin
who plays Thanos has got me thinking that
it won't be a main Avenger who we lose in
Infinity War.
When Brolin was asked about Thanos's daughters,
Nebula and Gamora, the actor found it difficult
to discuss.
Although he did say the Mad Titan treats both
Gamora and Nebula as tools for his own gain,
when pushed on whether Thanos is "cold the
whole way through, or [if] he feel[s] any
affection for them?", this is what Brolin
said:
"Yeah.
I do think he does.
When you see the relationship with Gamora
and you see that evolves, God I wish I could
tell you.
I can't!
Obviously he has a grand plan, like somebody
who's pulling in kids for their own selfish
bloodshed.
But he has a capacity to love very much and
very deeply."
Now, I think it's very interesting that Brolin
specifically mentioned Gamora but tried to
stop himself from revealing anything further
in terms of bigger plot points.
We need to remember that Gamora is Thanos's
favourite daughter and that favouritism has
been something that has been very painful
for her adoptive sister Nebula.
"Your demeanor is that of a pouty child."
"And, apparently, you alienated my favorite
daughter, Gamora."
So, why would Thanos kill Gamora?
Well, there's rumours that if Thanos does
get to all six Infinity Stones, he'll still
need something extra to be able to use the
Soul Stone.
That particular Infinity Stone still hasn't
been revealed in the MCU, though I've talked
about possible locations where it could appear
in my Soul Stone video, but the idea is that
to be able to use the Soul Stone you have
to sacrifice someone you love.
Thanos has a twisted love for his daughters,
and Gamora is his favourite, which could mean
Thanos will kill her in order to control the
Soul Stone.
But before you get too upset, just remember
we're talking comic book movies here, and
it's quite likely that the Infinity War sequel
will involve the Avengers trying to reverse
some of the events from Infinity War, perhaps
with time travel.
As for Marvel, killing Gamora would indeed
give their film an emotional hit, without
their having to retire one of the original
core characters like Iron Man or Cap at this
point.
And there's actually a bit of supporting evidence
for this idea in the form of one of the Infinity
War LEGO sets for the final battle in which
Iron Man, Gamora and Star-Lord face off against
Thanos who is wielding an Infinity Sword.
We don't know how this battle will go, but
it could be the moment in which Thanos carries
out his dastardly deed.
After all we do see Iron Man extremely upset
in this shot from the first trailer and it
looks like it could be set on Thanos's home
world Titan.
We also know that in Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2, Nebula came to terms with her sister
Gamora and seeing Thanos kill her would be
the final straw, setting up a huge revenge
story for her in Avengers 4.
"There are little girls like you across the
universe who are in danger."
"You can stay with us and help them."
"I will help them by killing Thanos."
"I don't know if that's possible."
"You will always be my sister."
Now, I really like Gamora, so I'll be pretty
devastated if this does play out.
However, Zoe Saldana has already revealed
she's been filming on Avengers 4, but she
could have been filming flashback scenes from
before her death or if that movie really does
reverse the events from Infinity War then,
of course, we might see Gamora come back to
life.
The really interesting thing in all this is
that Gamora's death would actually parallel
something which happened to her in the comics.
When Gamora discovered Thanos's master plan
to kill off half the universe, she attempted
to kill him with a dagger.
However, Thanos mortally wounded her and left
her for dead.
Adam Warlock found Gamora about to die and
to save her he absorbed her spirit into the
Soul Gem and took her into a place inside
the gem called Soulworld.
Gamora stayed in Soulworld until the events
of the Infinity Gauntlet when Adam Warlock
restored Gamora into the real world via the
body of a recently deceased human.
She died again though when Thanos erased half
of the universe from existence.
By the way, James Gunn has said we won't be
getting Adam Warlock in the Infinity War movie,
however, he'll likely appear in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3, and I talk about how
that will happen in my Adam Warlock teaser
video.
Nebula also plays a key part in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline and the final defeat of
Thanos.
Initially, in the Infinity Gauntlet comics,
Thanos wreaks havoc on Nebula's body, torturing
her and turning her into a living corpse who
he uses to try to impress Mistress Death.
Later in the story though, it's Nebula who
turns the balance of power away from Thanos
by taking the gauntlet from him.
Nebula then restores the half of the universe
which Thanos had killed, which also brings
back Gamora.
Now, I don't think this is exactly what will
happen in the movies, however, in this glimpse
of Nebula from the Super Bowl TV spot, we
can see that she's absolutely furious at something.
Could it be she's just witnessed Thanos appear
to kill her sister Gamora?
If Nebula, or another character, does reverse
Gamora's death or any other effects of Thanos's
devastation, that would happen in Avengers
4, not Infinity War, of course.
By the way, another possibility is that Marvel
might do a twist on this idea in the Infinity
War movie, with Thanos killing Nebula as she
goes up against him, rather than Gamora.
Nebula is still one of his daughters and so
could be used by Thanos to harness the power
of the Soul Stone, with Gamora then having
to exact revenge on the Mad Titan.
Either way, if Gamora or Nebula does die,
perhaps by having their souls taken from them
by Thanos, then this would be quite an emotional
set-up for Avengers 4.
So, do you think Gamora or Nebula will be
a casualty in Avengers: Infinity War or do
you have any theories on who else Thanos might
kill?
And which character would you be most upset
to lose in the movie?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments
below and subscribe for my new Marvel giveaway.
The winner of my Jessica Jones giveaway is
on screen now; if that's you, private message
me with your details so I can get your prize
sent out to you.
And while we all wait for the next Infinity
War trailer, check out my recent Avengers
videos and other Marvel theories by tapping
the screen here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!